hello everyone and welcome to the
penultimate round of the 2019 u.s.
championships we have a game between
Fabiana Caruana and Alexander Linderman
The Clash of leaders Dominguez vs.
Nakamura ended in a draw and a lot of
other games and in a draw but we'll get
back to that after we check out this
game so everything is on the line if
Caruana wants to catch up to the leaders
he he does have to win his game so let's
see how he did and it's a very
interesting opening choice for Linderman
as everyone was colonised famous for his
batter of defense so in this game
Linderman Chow chosen and none other
than the petro of defense so let's see
how it went we have E 4 E 5 Knight to f3
and now of course Knight to f6 Linderman
goes for the Petrov defense Knight
captures on e5 d6 and now Knight back to
f3 so the main line and it's also a very
nice psychological move from Linderman
side as well like I said Khurana is the
most famous for his bedroom defense in
the last year year and a half and well
he now has to show us how to play
against it which I don't think anyone
played against Caruana
so far at least not to my knowledge
but ok Knight captures only for
continuing in the main line and now
Caruana goes for nice to see 3 and I'm
very happy about this as it's my
favorite line how to play against the
petrov so i was all very curious on how
the game will go and here Lenderman
decided to go back with the knight
Knight to have 6 and avoid any trades
but I will show a nice line especially
if you're if you're a beginner and you
face the petrov oftentimes when Knight
captures and c3 is played you can just
recapture by D captures on c3 and
sometimes your opponent will go Bishop
to g4 just just a nice developing move
which is a bad move and you will often
be able to win blades games and maybe
even longer games but just going let's
say h3 Bishop h5 and now Queen d5 goes
with a double attack against the bishop
and the b7 pawn and here of course you
do not win material but black will have
to give up the bishop pair very early
and it will just enjoy a very open-ended
game with a bishop pair where all of
your well choices are just open you can
do whatever you want Castle kingside
developed the body shops and enjoy a
superior game but okay in this game
Knight to f6 was played we have d4 by
Caruana Bishop to e7 and now Bishop to
d3 with castles by black castles by
Caruana
nice to see six just developing and here
it's this move has been played a few
times of the stronger players who use
this line is you young you of China and
he he did have one such position in
Shenzhen against onigiri onigiri went
look to e1 and that game ended in a draw
but there was also one game that yongi
also played with the black pieces
against Wei Wei continued at the same
way Caruana did in this game with the d5
attacking the knight and here you young
he went to Knights to e5 and he was able
to beat Wei Yi in that game but here
Lenderman goes in Knights to b4 and it's
as of this move from move 9 we have a
completely new game so Carolina's idea
he wants to keep it the bishop pair he
goes Bishop to e2 and now c6 now both
nights and I from b4 night from f6 and
also the Seif at the C pawn attack
White's a very strong central pawn so
Corona decides to trade it with D
captures and c6 b captures on c6 and now
just a3 kicking away the night nice to
d5 as the other night is also guarding
the square Knight captures Knight
characters and not night to d4 and here
it's already a bit of a dangerous line
as a knight you could easily miss up by
playing something like c5 the knight c6
just wins the game your queen is under
attack and also your night here so we
just be losing a piece here however of
course Lenderman will not make such a
mistake he goes Bishop to d7 just guards
the D at the c6 pawn and Bishop to f3
here kuranes plan is the capture on d5
give up the bishop repair fairly early
in the game but also have a very nice
block inning knight on d4 linderman
continues with rook to c8 we have Bishop
captures on d5 as planned C capture Sun
d5 now corona I decided to give up the
bishop pair but in return he does have
this well it's not a monster night but
it's a very nice night
blocky locating both of
the double the deep on Slenderman has so
it's a trade-off but you know once once
these pawns start marching forward the
double deep one will be will be a
handicap for black but okay Bishop to e3
by Corona Bishop to f6 placing a better
planner much nicer diagonal Queen to d2
connecting rooks developing the Queen
and black does the same we have Queen to
c7 with ideas of maybe winning the sea
to ponder but so far there is no real
danger here
Corona just goes h3 and you can't win
the poem by something like special
captures I mean that's a very strong
Bishop even if you could win a pawn
you're not gonna do it because after
Queen captures you can't capture on c2
but then you lose the a 7-point your
Bishop is under attack and you will not
be able to do anything here if there
should be one attacks the rook then just
rook a c1 and you will have an excellent
game here with the white pieces the pawn
cannot be captured if you capture yet
another point then you get rook captures
rook captures and queen b7 attacks the
rook and the bishop and after the rook
moves wherever a 4 will just win the
window bishop as the queen is not sorry
sorry about that the queen is unguarded
on b2 so you know quite a quite a vivid
position rook F to e 8 my Linderman and
the now comes rook F to e 1 by karana
also he wants to develop the rook with
h6 by black and now just c3 no longer
karana has to worry about that c2 pawn
and also he's preparing b4 with Queen to
b7 just waiting to see what what white
will try Knight back to f3 we have
looked at east 6 preparing to double up
rooks on the e-file and now comes the
Bishop to d4 Bishop to e7 Lenderman
declines the the trade of darks were
bishops and now b4 by white now karana
is ready to push on the Queen side with
a 6 by black a4 by Caruana
and now comes a rook to e8 preparing to
move the bishop and the roofs will now
be doubled on the e-file King to h2
karana improves the position of its King
looked efore just a much nicer Square
for the rook before the rooks are
doubled as if white ever captures then
black will under his pawns so it's just
a
square for the rook rook eat the b1
Khurana no longer is interested in any
play in the central around the King side
he wants to really start pushing on the
Queen side and create a passport if
possible
Bishop to d8 now the roofs are doubled
the bishop has moved and now b5 and here
you could go something like rook to e2
but it doesn't really do anything just
Queen b3 you're you know giving further
support to the b5 point doesn't really
do anything for black so here black
tried a 5 which does stop the the the
pawn expansion on the Queen side
somewhat but still white now has a past
beep on rook to be to corona now is
preparing to double rooks on the B file
we have Quint a 8 now comes the Queen to
d3 and just Queen back to b7 black still
trying to keep everything together
seeing what Cora wanna we'll come up
with first night the b2 Reema nuvaring
the night going after the week a
five-point but first also black has to
decide what to do with the rook we look
to f4 and now Knight the b3 attacking
the a 5 point but of course the the real
idea is b6 our cutting of the bishops
defense of the a 5 point here we have
Bishop to a5 attacking kuranes Queen and
now Queen to g3
now threatening checkmate on g7
Linderman decides to cover that as the
rookies also attack on attacked on f4
you have to play g5 to defend everything
there's no more checkmate and also the
rook on f4 is guarded
we have b6 now cutting off if captured
with the bishop then you get under the
mask of the rook
once the discovery is made Queen to a6
now with with defense towards the a 5
pawn Knight back to d2 and now a
Linderman just goes Bishop the back to
d7 attacking the a4 pawn but Khurana
doesn't mind he plays rook a to be 1 and
you cannot capture the point because b7
and there's no stopping that pawn so
here after locate the b1 we have Queen -
b7 blocking the pawn and now Knight back
to b3 attacking the a5 pawn Lenderman
repeats as he well he does have a bit of
a difficult position so he definitely
wouldn't mind the draw here Knights the
c1 Khurana
a different plan with the night Queen to
be seven back blocking locating the
b-pawn but now night the d3 and now it's
already well quite difficult to decide
what to do with the rook if you move it
you can wait to have sex bishop is
guarding that square if you just move
that Queen will capture the d6 Pond and
d5 pawn will fall as well white will
just be at material it will be it will
be an easy game for white so here
instead or if you go something like yeah
like rook to h4 also possible but then
again Queen will capture on d6 and it
will just be better for white so here at
Linderman decided to give up the
exchange he played Bishop he played rook
captures on d4 grabbing her on a strong
dark square bishop we have seek after
sandy for and not look the e6 defending
the d6 pawn but now it's it's just a
hard game with Knight to f4 karana takes
this opportunity as the G pawn is pinned
you cannot capture the rook has to move
rook goes to e4 and now comes Knight to
e2 again the Queen opens up an attack
against the d6 pawn and then now white
plays Bishop captures on a4 at least now
black also created a past a 5-point
Knight to c3 now corona finds a very
nice tactic the rook is now under attack
and also the bishop rook captures on d4
and now comes the idea first Queen
captures on d6 with an attack against
the bishop here Bishop to e7 forcing the
Queen back and now Queen to e5 and now
the rook is under attack you have to do
something about this and there is really
nowhere for you to move the rook as you
also have to keep an eye on the bishop
here you could try something like rook
to f4 but then you okay you're still
protecting the bursa but then just night
after Sun d5 and the black will very
soon fall apart the rook is under attack
the bishop on e7 is under attack twice
so not not something who can defend so
after Queen 35 a Linderman decided to
play rook to e4 giving up yet another
exchange
Kerwin accepted we have Knight captures
on e4 d captures on e4 and now just look
the c1 and it was in this position
unmoved 47 that alexander lindgren
resigned the game and Fabiana corona
were a former rule chess championship
Challenger indeed showed us how to play
against the patter of defense and you
know he did he did without without too
much problems it would seem but yeah why
did black resign
well rook to c7 is coming there's not
all that much you can do about it you
can try blocking the pawn
let's temperature before but now just to
rock c7 and after Queen moves now you
can just do a little tactic rook
captures pawn captures and now after b7
there's really nothing to do against
roof to c8 if Bishop to d7 what's the
idea that if rook captures black Queen
captures your queen with check there's a
very nice idea here but I haven't asked
you to pause the video this video so do
it now and find the win for for white
it's it's not all that complicated but
you know if you're interested I will
give it a couple of seconds for you to
decide well I have a nice sip of my
water for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent spender of your or fewer
Sunday time and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy the show the idea of
course is rook to see it check and now
white wins because you will either
capture the rook with the Queen and then
pawn recaptures and you will just be up
a queen or you will capture with the
rook but then Queen captures Queen
pinning the bishop you will get another
Queen whatever black does doesn't really
matter you will capture this Queen bring
another queen into the game and black
will be checkmated fairly soon Sam after
work to c1 Lenderman resigned and well i
well deserved victory for Caruana and
the much-needed one as he now climbs
back into the top I also prepare the
standings here here we have him a nice
cross table from chess 24 website I also
put a link to it in the description
below as you will also be able to find
some other information there so after
the penultimate round we have one more
round to go
it's Dominguez Dominguez in linear
Dominguez Perez in first place with
seven points also with seven points
Fabiano Khurana with did this win
Nakamura also with seven points after
after his clash with Dominguez in the in
this round then with six points Wesley
so Samuel 705 and a half then with five
points
Geoffrey Sheung and Samuel Franklin with
four points
I wonder Lee and a team or grave I
managed to climb
operated with three and a half points
alongside Lenderman and in the Ray
Robson and in last place with three
points a grandmaster
Varro's and a cobia so there you have it
and in the last round we're gonna have
really an interesting class it will be
Jeffrey's young against Hikaru Nakamura
Nakamura will have the black pieces he
has to win this if he wants a chance to
win first place then we will have
Domingues will Dominguez will face a
team or Karev Dominguez will have the
white pieces in that clash so I believe
Dominguez has the best shot of winning
the US Championship 2019 but also in the
last round Seminole Shanklin with the
white pieces faces Fabiana Cora Juana
so if Corona wants to win he has to
defeat the former US Champion
Samuel Shanklin with the black pieces so
it will be definitely gonna be
interesting we'll see what happens
you know it's just anything could happen
so you know they're definitely looking
forward to it yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you've
enjoyed my short coverage of the of the
US Championship I would like to thank
Anton Kukushkin Brian Anderson Danno
Hanlon
Jorge ROTC georgiou and the giga brain
schmidt for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
I'm very happy to see that the down
O'Hanlon still still you are enjoying my
content you are one of one of the first
subscribers on this channel and and also
one of my first supporters so very happy
to hear that
oh yeah as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here think of for
watching and I will see you soon with
some more interesting content hopefully
and you know how it goes so thank you
all have an excellent rest of your
Sunday and like I said I will see you
soon and once again do check out if you
haven't I will put a link in the
description below the trailer for the
blanket just classic festival
now really thank you all and have an
excellent rest of your Sunday